وبما اننا نتحدث عن رمضان الشاي معنا
دائما والسؤال الذي نطرحه اليوم ما هو
الشعب الاكثر استهلاكا للشاي هذا السؤال
اجابت عنه بيانات مؤسسه ولكن جديد بالذكر
قبل ذلك هو ان الشاي هو المشروب الاكثر
استهلاكا في العالم بعد الماء البيانات
جمعت احصات حول استهلاك الشاي العالمي من
56 بلدا حول العالم وقد تصدرت تركيا
القائمه حيث اقرت تسعه اشخاص من اصل 10
منهم بانهم يشربون الشاي بانتظام اما
كينيا احد اهم منتجيه شايفه جاءت في
المركز الثاني برفقه باكستان فيما احتل
المغرب المركز الرابع حيث 80% من
المشاركين يشربون الشاي هناك الهند حلت
خامسه في الترتيب وفي المركز السادس
والسابع جاءت ايرلندا وبريطانيا
حول العالم خلال 2023 الى
247 مليار دولار